well I thought we'd kick off by doing a
little experiment with you Brady
I've got some weights here and I want to
see how sensitive your hands are that
don't mean I want you to lift some
weights this is a workout session and I
wanted to see if you can tell the
difference between how heavy different
things are so I think when we take
camera it's fine Freddie you're fine
you're fine it's not the most flattering
angle a which one of those is heavier
that one correct correct answer right so
that one is and I look yeah a hundred
and twenty grams okay and then your
other hand you have a hundred grams okay
okay now I'm gonna make it slightly
harder you could tell the difference
between 120 and 100 so you can sense 20
gram difference then
[Applause]
is what you're shooting vaguely usable
type thing okay and now okay now I feel
like that's heavier incorrect so that is
200 grams and 220 and you can't tell the
difference and there is a reason for
that okay okay so what was going on
there is something that Ernest Weber
discovered in 1834 we need to do exactly
this experiment he noticed that even
though you can sense a small change in
between two weights when the initial
weight is very small as that initial
weight gets bigger you can no longer
detect that change the just noticeable
difference that you need changes
depending on the size of the weights now
this led him to come up with an equation
which is known as Weber's law that small
difference that tiny change in the
intensity if you like a bit of the
feeling depends it's a ratio really that
you're you're sensing and that ratio is
constant so although you can detect a 20
gram difference when you've got 100
grams in your hand you can't detect it
when you're at 200 grams you need a much
bigger difference that small it's just
noticeable difference before you can
detect it and the thing is is that
although in weights you know often in
that situation where you're testing
different ways actually I think that
this Weber's law applies to a lot of
different situations so you know if
you're in a really dark room and someone
maybe turns on their iPhone torch and
you can see it kind of like lights up
the entire room but when you're in a
really bright room if someone flicked on
their torture with me you wouldn't
notice the difference
and this explains why as you get older
years seem as though they're going
faster time kind of speeds up as you get
older right even though a year is the
same length always the ratio of how long
that year is to how long your life has
been ends up getting smaller and smaller
and smaller so how it feels changes over
time
so this here is Weber's law but what it
means is that the way that we experience
things in in life actually follows a
logarithm so if you think about how
something feels your response to
something and then you compare that to
the sort of intensity of whatever it is
you're feeling so this could be light
can be sound it could be weights the way
that this changes it takes sort of this
shape here it's kind of a logarithmic
shape so what that means is if you start
off down here and you're a very low
weight okay and then you take a really
tiny change in the weight so this 20
gram change so this is gonna be I this
would be I plus Delta I the difference
how that feels is gonna be quite big but
then if you're over here so now this one
will be sort of a hundred grams down
here and let's say when you're over here
you're up at 200 grams made the y-axis
do small even if you take the same
change in weight so I first after I
let's make this I 1 and I naught that
same change in stimulus it's gonna feel
like almost nothing in your response so
essentially what this means is the way
that we feel stuff the way that we
perceive stuff in life doesn't follow a
linear relationship it actually follows
a logarithmic relationship which is what
this curve and here is my thing that is
quite interesting because when you come
across and logarithms first in school
which I think they're you know when
you're sort of 16 or 17 they feel really
counterintuitive they feel like they
don't really make much sense but
actually that's exactly how you perceive
the world the exact parameters on this
curve change depending on what you're
talking about so they'll be wonderful
light there'll be another curve
of how quickly it goes up and how
quickly it bends over but the basic
mathematical structure of this which has
been shown time and time again in all
sorts of different experiments is that
we perceive things logarithmically if
there is an amount a change in stimulus
that you can just about notice and we
know exactly because of this equation
where that it is depending on and what
you're talking about people who do
marketing use this completely to their
advantage so I swear the Cadbury Dairy
Milk over time has gradually got smaller
and smaller and smaller and no doubt it
probably has but the people who make
these decisions know this equation know
the way that we perceive things is
logarithmic and know the exact amount
that they can shrink their chocolate bar
by before you notice that that's what
they've done
oh they're also a really expensive items
they know that they can creep up the
price by a much bigger sum before you'll
notice that the price has changed
whereas things like things that are
really cheap you know buying sort of
pints of milk or eggs or whatever you've
got to be a lot more careful you can
only eat get up by a couple of pennies
before people start to notice well so
the reason why I came across this was
because I was doing some research into
how judges make sentences and how they
decide on sentences and actually this
stuff becomes really important it's not
just sort of people trying to make a
little bit more money or noticing
different size weights three months in
jail is three months in jail it doesn't
matter whether you have been in jail for
you know three months already or if
you've been in jail for thirty years
already three months of jail cost the
same amount of money the taxpayer you
still depriving someone of their freedom
that the same amount but the thing is is
that a six-month jail term feels a lot
longer than a three-month jail term but
a twenty year and three months jail term
doesn't really feel like that much more
than twenty year jail term so as a
result there's this study which looks at
the the sentences that people give out
that judges around the world give out
and there are these huge gaps in the
timelines that are available to them and
it's because of this it's because it
doesn't it just doesn't feel like enough
of a difference to give someone a
sentence that's not one of these kind of
preferred numbers so you get lots and
lots of fine granular sentences down low
and then you just get nice big round
numbers like 20 years and 30 years
because people think logarithmically
thank you for watching now in the past
you've probably heard me talk about
brilliant the site full of puzzles and
quizzes and lessons all about
mathematics and science the people who
make it are guided by eight principles
of learning you can read all about them
cultivating curiosity is one I relate to
for example here's a problem from
brilliant if the earth suddenly stopped
spinning
mayhem would ensue I think that is
perhaps a slight understatement but
let's continue what would happen to
objects on the surface now quite aside
from answering this question what I like
is clicking here to discuss solutions
all sorts of people are explaining how
they worked out and others are
commenting on it it's not just about the
answer I really like seeing how its
explained its cultivating my curiosity
now if you'd like to check out brilliant
go to brilliant org slash numberphile so
they know you came from here there's
loads of free stuff on the site but the
URL below will give you 20% off a
premium membership with access to even
more stuff our thanks to brilliant for
supporting this episode and we'll see
you again soon
you